are you looking for a good show to watch
on netflix are you also looking to not
have to explain cults execution graphic
language and sex to your kids while
watching well we've got you covered
here's netflix gems that are great to
binge just not with your children
co-created by comedian nick kroll big
mouth is a perfect example of something
that looks like it should be for
children but absolutely isn't big mouth
is a raunchy animated comedy that
follows a group of seventh graders as
they navigate the awkwardness and
uncertainty of puberty sure it's got
goofy looking characters and even a few
musical numbers but make no mistake big
mouth is unequivocally are rated
episodes examine the nitty-gritty of
menstruation sexuality hygiene and team
dating while it often offers
thought-provoking lessons about speaking
to kids about these issues letting them
watch it outright is the equivalent of
tossing them into the deep end of the
swimming pool without water wings for
example the first episode sees andrew
glauberman one of our young protagonists
interacting with his hormone monster
mori who is essentially puberty
incarnate maury encourages andrew to
think constantly about sex fall into
blind rages and enter into nightmarishly
ill-conceived relationships big mouth
portrays all sorts of things with
compassion and insight but not in any
way suited for young impressionable
children put the kids to bed wait at
least an hour and then indulge in its
animated antics
that was astounding
set in a sword and sorcery style fantasy
world this enchantment tells the story
of bean the rough and tumble princess of
dreamland while her fairy tale destiny
is to marry a handsome prince and unite
streamland with another politically
advantageous kingdom all she wants to do
is drink fight gamble and go on
adventures created by matt groening
disenchantment is similar in tone to his
other shows futurama and the simpsons as
is the case with those two series some
parents might be perfectly fine watching
this enchantment with their kids while
others might not want to pause and
explain jokes about alcohol and one
night stands kids will likely get a kick
out of seeing the elves in their
homeland singing about making candy
however some explanation might be needed
when they attempt to hang one of their
own while gleefully singing about
execution as a parent the choice to let
your kids watch what they want is up to
you however if you find yourself wanting
to check out this enchantment and your
little ones get hooked by its bright
colours and funny voices be warned you
might end up discussing the logistics of
killing someone with a candy axe
it becomes pretty apparent early on the
black mirror is not for kids the first
episode does after all tell the story of
a kidnapper who demands that the british
prime minister have sex with a pig on
live television well most episodes
aren't quite as raunchy as a series
opener many may have heard it compared
to the twilight zone over the years
while that's an abs description rod
sterling's original series consists
mostly of family-friendly morality tales
sure a whole lot of them are scary but
not in a way kids can't handle
existential scares are a whole lot
different than say the discomfort
induced by the whole pig thing black
mirror is a show that gets into the
intimate horror of a world overrun by
digitization episodes deal with murder
sex grief exploitation and many more
twisted things that can't be adequately
explained without spoiling numerous
plots virtual realities are used for
torture internet-enabled toys wreak
havoc androids built to bring loved ones
back from the grave are hidden in attics
kids have surveillance tech implanted in
their brains allowing parents to censor
their little ones realities it's
terrific but it's not exactly kid
friendly
stick to sharing twilight zone reruns
with your children and save black mirror
for yourself
the witcher is based on the popular
witch of video games which are in turn
based on a popular series of books your
kids might in fact be more familiar with
the show than you are in this age of
let's place but that doesn't mean it's a
candidate for family tv night the series
follows geralt of rivia as he hunts
fights and kills various monsters and
other worldly beasts this
happens all the time when his journey
leads him to yennefer a powerful
sorceress his life of killing for hire
is entirely upset and that's before the
kid destined to travel with him gets
into the picture the witcher is one of
the most violent scary and sexual shows
on this list if those warnings aren't
enough to keep your kids away from
gerald's story perhaps showrunner lauren
s hissrix tweet about the show not being
kid friendly will be enough to convince
you trust her when she posted just watch
the cut of witcher with my son and the
verdict is in this show is not for
five-year-olds like really not you
really don't want to have to explain
undead monsters wartime suicide and
magical cults to your little one
kids might love superheroes but not all
superhero fiction is for kids take
jessica jones one of marvel's netflix
offerings the series might feature super
strength but it also examines sexual
assault trauma and alcoholism the
titular jessica is a new york city-based
private investigator she's a hard
drinker played by memories of the car
accident that killed her parents and
left her with super powers but that's
not all she has to contend with jessica
jones first season pits the pi against
kilgrave the man who used his mind
controlling powers to abuse her for
years jessica jones explores scenes that
are very important to tackle with
children from consent to post-traumatic
stress however the show isn't a psa and
often sees its characters deal with
their issues in self-destructive ways
there's no shortage of superhero content
out there that's totally fine to watch
alongside one's kids but not jessica
jones at first he used seems like a love
story it focuses on a young bookstore
clerk named joe who bonds with people
over literature in a technology obsessed
culture he's particularly enamored with
one woman named gwyneverbeck will you
tell the tale of their romance in short
the answer is no despite seeming to be
an analogue guy in a digital world joe
is very tech savvy he's able to stalk
beck's social media and orchestrate meek
cute as a result of his twisted
obsession and we do mean twisted joe
kills bex's ex steals her underwear and
spies on her you is most definitely not
for kids but its appeal to youth is
strong after all it's entirely about
social media add in some graphic
language violence and nudity then you've
got exactly the sort of catnip kids are
eager to grow up gravitating towards
make no mistake however u is for
grown-ups alone you might wish you had
your kid around to explain some of the
intricacies of social media but trust us
it's better to just google it yourself
there are scary people in the world bec
that's why it's important to be safe sex
education focuses on a group of high
school teens as they navigate the
pitfalls of growing up popularity and of
course sex what that might sound like
one of the mil teen drama it's a
genuinely funny heartfelt series but
seriously a whole lot of it is about sex
those who tune in will be introduced to
otis milburn a socially awkward teen who
has a lot of questions about the birds
and the beasts he's a lot better
equipped to answer them than most teens
however his mother is a professional sex
therapist she's fine with speaking
candidly about the topic in front of her
son but consequences arrive when otis
knowledge increases his profile at
school otis begins to dole out sex
advice to his classmates leading to very
difficult to explain situations like a
chlamydia outbreak among the student
body now parents should definitely
educate their kids about things like
sexually transmitted illness however sex
education is still entertainment at
heart and shouldn't be used as a
textbook its focus is to get laughs and
it gets them but you're better off
having a frank discussion with your kids
yourself
kids often grow bored flipping through
the list of potential shows to watch and
settle on something with a fun title
when it comes to titles it doesn't get
more fun than peaky blinders it's got a
slightly goofy name and appears to be a
cops and robbers show at first glance
but make no mistake this show is
anything but kid-friendly the show
focuses on a gangster family living in
1919 birmingham england just after world
war one ravaged the globe it tells the
story of the real-life peaky blinders
gang that clashed with law enforcement
sent over by winston churchill the show
is violent foul-mouthed and deals with a
lot of subject matter that frankly some
adults aren't ready for let alone
children just as one should never judge
a book by its cover one should never
judge a tv show based on its title
however that doesn't mean that this
critically acclaimed drama is a bad show
far from it it's worth a watch just not
with your kids
if you grew up playing the old
castlevania games on the nintendo
entertainment system or super nes you
might see the animated series of the
same name on netflix and assume that it
too is appropriate for kids or maybe you
just assume that if it's animated it's
probably fine for younger audiences to
enjoy but make no mistake castlevania is
not for kids and in fact is one of the
greatest shows on the entire streaming
platform castlevania is really a story
about the king of vampires and demons
declaring war on humankind and it
doesn't shy away from any of the darker
implications of that towns are
slaughtered on screen and the monsters
themselves are grotesque and disturbing
there are dark rituals magic spells gone
horribly wrong gruesome deaths the whole
shebang this is definitely one animated
series that your kids should not be
watching with you for age-appropriate
audiences however castlevania is stylish
and compelling the animation is brutal
at times but it can also be gorgeous and
the cast of characters assembled across
the four seasons are all interesting and
fun to watch the show excels are big
battle scenes but its best moments more
often than not are simple conversations
between characters a lot of intriguing
themes are exploring castlevania you
just have to be okay with the heavy
level of gore to get there
shall we
dota dragon's blood falls into a very
similar category to castlevania an
animated series based on a popular video
game designed with mature audiences in
mind it's definitely not as far down the
trail of occult themes dark imagery and
disembowelments that castlevania is
however it's still far from a kid's show
with plenty of blood violence and sex to
drive that point home the tone and
content of dota dragon's blood map
pretty cleanly onto the adult fantasy
genre with a tv ma rating the series
makes it clear up front that this is
meant for adult fans of the video game
and animated fantasy in general not kids
still if you're looking for a series of
similar visual flair to watch with your
children netflix has some other great
options from dota animator studio mia
voltron legendary defender and kippo and
the age of wonder beasts or if you want
something a little more fantasy inspired
and aren't too attached to the animation
style shira and the princesses of power
is a great watch for all ages
hopefully no one would ever mistake
squid game for a kid-appropriate program
no matter how popular it may be the
smash-hit korean thriller about a deadly
underground competition involves brutal
reimaginings of some classic children's
playground games even still it's
impossible to mistake this series for
anything other than what it is a dark
terrifying takedown of capitalist creed
filled with violent gladiator matches
disguised as games squid game is
fantastic it became netflix's biggest
show ever in 2021 despite the fact that
as a non-english series the odds were
severely stacked against it and creator
huang dong-hyuk and the stars of the
show deserve every bit of praise they've
received but this is certainly not a
show for kids and you definitely should
keep it off and away when younger
viewers are around
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite netflix shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one